welcome to this video Savanti pillar
okay cute name I hadn't played him
before this is cocos islands okay yeah
the Benoni or not the other let's let's
do something conservative here very
often the Benoni guys they don't really
feel at home in this type of positions
okay we transpose to a new zone now
maybe actually just play the names oh
okay interesting quickie Quincy 7 mm-hmm
okay I can just play Queenie too if I
want maybe not clear I cannot suggest we
could have moved the bishop I'm not very
afraid of him snatching upon yeah but so
not clear that I have to allow that okay
so this is very much like the cup of
variation but he has not played b6 yet
interesting
I'm not totally sure about what setup I
should go for going for this with see
for now and maybe he can take maybe you
can take and play five but ok it's um
and I g4 is also possible ok maybe not
the the best possible said abre I'm not
so much at home in this type of position
94 I played should be four but I think
he can consider to take on f3 and then
go if I've maybe maybe you should buy
three Queen a 3 e far left I have Queen
geez Queen g3 though which is quite
quite interesting ok so should I play
maybe I should prevent an IG fort so
he's got night h5 sometimes ok is a four
a five a move ok I don't want to fall
even more behind on the clock ok so here
maybe he just wants to shake and go five
yeah just bishops III maybe and that's
95 I but I can take that rook takes
takes only six shouldn't be too bad
right
night h5 gains a little bit in strength
than but okay I have Queen III Bishop
everyone IDs me
whatever you can say about him is
playing oakley 95 million I don't know
maybe I'm overlooking something here but
I think white is just in good shape here
at Bishop a6i he's got Bishop a six hmm
that was a bad oversight I was thinking
Lambert is not doing it ok I was
thinking and go now this is not not such
such a big problem he could have played
Bishop a six but he's the kind of guy
will just play since Andrews and hoped
for the best ice I think okay here I'm
here I'm certainly all right but not
sure how good it is dd5 maybe d-force
hanging and he's got knight c6 d5 would
prevent that but it's it's a bit of a
shaky situation on the D foul it's
probably right nevertheless but ok now
I've got Luke a 7 cannot really
calculate here or this with one minute
thirty it's a bit bit of a problem rook
da de maybe just rugby aid and it's not
not clear what I'm doing now night see a
dessert is a move ok maybe I should just
take it now
yeah all those pieces here on the double
shop CM thru key came just want this
piece of the D ha
champ difficult difficult why this
obviously better here but I just have
one minute and I this look at some of
course the problem I don't know what's
this move g5 is just very very hard to
understand okay don't know what he's
doing him
and simply no no big point to climb work
to what he did I think I don't don't
really understand it ok I can go here
tutitu it's got this check here but it's
not doing that much ok I always have
worked reform
check-check
30 seconds I could have given the check
their check check check check check
check
check draw Alfred check google offered
check check check yeah that's just great
chess what you're playing baby check
light for its ninth I'm being worse
basically the whole time and then win
Luke against Luke on time it's also way
to gain rating points yeah Jim exactly
did I spend so much time yeah here with
gypsies c3 and of course I'm worried
about things that he's not even
considering he Bishop a six is just good
I overlooked the move to completely but
he played this and here of course yeah
blackest black is in trouble after d5
yeah it's pretty good up to here this
should a 5s little bit better yeah it
keeps an advantage of course it's the
bishop pair and the B porn but by now
I'm so much download time that g5 is a
joke of course of it okay ever I
shouldn't shouldn't really analyze what
black did here and three useless yeah
Bishop see one is better yeah i was
thinking that this is such a simplifying
matters i didn't make a play a little
bit quicker but um it's it's so much
down time wise then it's it's difficult
to play catch-up I mean I managed to get
Luke against rukan easily but Jack chant
it's just not jetta you place this on
time even with our pawns yeah not much
to say about the game just the typical
kind of behavior that you see you all
the time okay thanks
chain